We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's an interesting voicemail that came
in this morning.
David, this is was off again.
You know, I'm actually very nervous about
this election.
Do you think your brother.
This matter was for Trump?
Because we'll never get a dictatorship to
democracy.
It's terrifying.
Democracy is dead.
And I have my granddaughter, who's around
nine months old, is going to grow up and finally
give the country united.
Good morning.
Thanks for all your reporting and good luck.
They say stay healthy.
OK.
So but listen, I get the frustration.
We have a president with dictatorial authoritarian
tendencies and a sort of wish for that.
He's a wannabe.
You are correct that many of the democratic
institutions of this country are in crisis
and they are in jeopardy.
But to go further right now and to say this
is a dictatorship is is simply not accurate.
I do think it's important to be, on the one
hand, warning people about signs and symptoms.
But on the other hand, we don't want to be
hyperbolic.
But the frustration.
I'm with you.
We have an opportunity to do something about
it very soon.
Let's actually do it.
We've got a great bonus show planned for you
today.
We will talk about the upcoming RNC and DNC
conventions and our plans for coverage.
We will talk about this Maskell's rally of
motorcyclists in South Dakota.
And much more.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
members at join Pacman dot com.
I'll see you then.